today on the matt walsh show mass
hysteria has gripped hold of our nation
people are so hysterical that many are
now begging for nuclear war but closer
to home on a smaller scale we see the
hysteria and the proliferation of racism
hoaxes especially in our schools
speaking of which there have been three
in our schools in just the past week or
two we'll talk about that plus ukrainian
president zielenski addresses congress
and asks for a no-fly zone which would
lead directly to world war iii small
little detail and a funny thing when
most americans are told what's actually
in the so-called don't say gay bill they
support it plus lawmakers want to hold
social media companies responsible for
making our children addicted to the
internet and in our daily cancellation
lawmakers also now plan to make daylight
savings permanent i'll explain why
that's a bad idea and might in fact
bring about the end of human
civilization all of that and more today
on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so do you really control your retirement
money if you've got a 401k or ira or
similar retirement plan the government
actually controls it they decide how
much you can borrow and when you must
pay it back and you'll owe taxes and
penalties for taking money out too soon
or waiting too long even though it's all
your money and thanks to the
skyrocketing national debt who knows how
much you'll have to pay in taxes during
a retirement they could last 30 years
bake on yourself is a better way to grow
and protect your hard earned money you
can access
your money for any purpose with no
questions asked and even use it for
purchases or opportunities without
interrupting the growth of those dollars
this is the strategy famous businesses
used when no banker would lend them a
dime and almost anyone can do it your
plan also doesn't go backward when the
market tumbles both your principal and
growth are locked in the best part is
that you have control of your money
without government penalties or
restrictions on how much income you can
take or when you can take it you don't
have to beg permission or pledge your
firstborn to use your money as it should
be so you can get a free report with all
the details of how adding bank on
yourself to your financial plan can help
you take back control of your money just
go to bankonyourself.comwalsh
that's
bankonyourself.com walsh this
information is for educational purposes
only and is not a solicitation for the
purchase of any financial product all
guarantees are based on the claims
paying ability of the insurer
you know people as a group when
taking the shape of a mob have always
been susceptible to mass hysteria
history provides of course many examples
but recent history provides many more
examples a new example each day it seems
because modern media and modern methods
of communication are the perfect
delivery system for the sorts of
psychological contagions which lead to
hysteria now we're seeing this play out
with respect to the war in ukraine many
americans
who couldn't point to ukraine on a map
three weeks ago and probably still can't
nonetheless now have ukrainian flags in
their bios and appear to feel greater
patriotic pride for this for you know
this foreign country that they've never
been to and know nothing about than for
their own country that it's hysteria
it's not rational thought
and now the latest pew research poll
shows that 35 percent of americans
nearly a third
favor taking direct military action
against russia even if it means risking
nuclear war that was written in the
question if it meant risking nuclear war
would you still want to get involved to
protect ukraine 35 of americans said yes
now these people
who again know almost nothing about this
conflict or the countries involved
would risk their own children's lives
for the sake of ukraine they would risk
global death on an unimaginable scale
for ukraine
they don't know why they feel this way
they can't explain it
but they do
it's mass hysteria now we'll get back to
ukraine later but as i said our capacity
for mass hysteria extends far beyond the
current conflict overseas it invades
every aspect of our lives we see it on
every level
everywhere and this is where all the
racist hate hoaxes also come from now
they're both
um they're they are born from a sort of
hysteria an obsession with being the
victim a need for attention
and the hoaxes also take advantage of
that same proclivity towards hysteria in
the general public so here's an example
closer home smaller scale actually three
examples um so we'll start with this
a student at our lady of mercy school
for young women in rochester which is a
grade 6-12 school
claimed last week i've discovered racist
graffiti in the bathroom
of course protests followed you know
kids were protesting
lots of media coverage
you know how this works and you also
know where it's going but before we get
there here's a local media reporting on
the conclusion of this case while
leaving something important out listen
to this
but first a breaking update to a local
story that's gotten a lot of traction
our lady of mercy school officials say
they know who was behind racist graffiti
in one of the bathrooms a fellow student
the message said the all-girls school is
filled with a bunch of quote n-words
administrators discovered it earlier
this week brighton police immediately
began investigating the case as a hate
crime this afternoon school leaders tell
us one of their students confessed to
writing that message they say the
maximum disciplinary action has already
been taken also in their statement the
school says mercy will work to help heal
the wounds caused by this incident as
well as help heal deep-rooted related
feelings this incident has brought to
the surface brighton police have not
charged the students
so the investigation concluded
they found the culprit
raises the question as to you know first
of all why they were investigating
scribblings on a middle school bathroom
stall as a federal crime
so they were investigating it as a hate
crime which means a federal crime
because some kid supposedly wrote
something in marker on a bathroom stall
now of course we don't really need to
ask the question as to why they're doing
that we already know it's part of the
mass hysteria and it's that same stereo
that that somehow prevents people from
seeing that this was obviously a hoax
from the beginning these things in
recent history are literally always
hoaxes
i mean always
though in this case um the authorities
involved refused to come out and say so
here's the post-millennial
says brighton police chief david
catholdis said quote we have shared the
results of our investigation with olm
they have
decided to handle the matter internally
and not pursue criminal charges several
students at the school shared the
offending message to at primetime 585
which is the twitter handle of karen
iglesia a local woman who chronicles
section 5 sports and has developed a
close relationship with many high school
athletes at the beginning of the week
iglesia posted an image of the racist
graffiti on twitter she said quote my
inbox was flooded today from olm high
school girls the twitter account this
note was written in the bathroom and
they had issues on how the
administration dealt with it they many
athletes all white begged me to post it
because they were so upset at how
trivial the school made it
iglesia wrote on monday afternoon
rochester area radio talk show host bob
lansbury tweeted that four sources
including two in government said the
culprit was an african-american student
quote not true she's hispanic a hispanic
not considered african-american in no
way iglesia responded on twitter in a
quote tweet replying to lonsbury so you
got two people on the ground there
both confirming they're they're debating
whether african-american or hispanic but
confirming it was not a white student
so it's what we've seen many times a
cycle from which we cannot escape
somebody often a child
commits an obvious hoax
everyone loses their minds
and then and then we simply move on
after it's proven to be a hoax having
not learned any lesson at all nobody
ever retracts anything they said there's
never any kind of apology
this was made clear over in minnesota
recently as well listen to this story
from wcco in minneapolis
says quote the superintendent of new
prague area schools says allegations of
a racist chant at a girls basketball
game last month could not be
substantiated by the school's
investigations robinsdale area schools
released a statement after the february
15th game between cooper high school in
new prague saying
according to several accounts some
spectators made monkey sounds directed
at the cooper team many of the cooper
players are black he said about 20
people who were at the game were
interviewed and none reported hearing
monkey noises the superintendent also
said no one reported hearing any noises
on the night of the game and the
district only learned of the allegation
via social media after the fact
so after the game on social media a few
accounts claim they heard
monkey sounds whatever that means
and they extrapolated from this
ambiguous sound that they allegedly
heard that white people in the stands
were being racist towards black players
on the court now
um call me crazy but i would say really
the racism comes in when if you hear a
sound
and it vaguely sounds like a monkey
sound and then you you immediately
assume that it's directed at black
people
i would think that that makes you the
racist if anything
you know if it were me and i heard
something like that i heard a sound what
was that i wouldn't draw that connection
immediately
anyway the school district investigated
interviewed 20 people
discovered that nobody in the room heard
these sounds and also that nobody who
was present for the event reported
anything of the sort
does that mean we can move forward now
relieved yet another allegedly racist
act was a figment of somebody's
imagination no of course not
because the report continues in a
message to families new product
superintendent
tim
ditburner
somehow just a perfect last name for
this guy i don't know why said while the
investigation found the allegations of
the racist chant could not be
substantiated the findings of this
investigation neither negate the lived
experiences of robbinsdale cooper's
student-athletes and staff nor does it
absolve the new prague area schools of
its responsibility to create a culture
that does not tolerate inappropriate
behavior ditburner reiterated a
three-step plan to address the school
culture so these incidents do not happen
in the future
that plan includes creating a school
climate task force professional
development and resources for staff and
also working with student leaders
okay so
the racist chant
doesn't appear to have happened
because of course it didn't happen
because it's just beyond belief that a
bunch of parents at a girls basketball
game would start making monkey sounds at
black players but even though it didn't
happen
we still must
respect the lived experience of people
who think it did happen
what's more the superintendent did
burner felt the need to reiterate that
he won't tolerate the kind of behavior
that didn't actually occur and he's
putting in place policies and plans to
address this non-existent activity and
ensure that the stuff that isn't
happening
continues to not happen
but wait there's more the superintendent
made reference to incidents plural at
the school later in his statement he
said that well even if this racist thing
didn't happen other racist stuff has
happened recently
what were what racist events was he
referring to well according to a local
nbc affiliate a few students in the
stands during a hockey match
also recently flashed a quote white
supremacist hand symbol
now
the symbol was the ok sign which is not
actually a racist symbol and which we
know for a fact was only connected to
racism because of a 4chan hoax a few
years ago i mean you can go back and
look at the posts where they came up
with this and said hey wouldn't it be
funny if we pretended that this was a
racist symbol so we know that it's all a
hoax
and yet continually people get in
trouble for you know doing this with
their hands
the offenders in this case explained
afterwards that they had no idea that
the symbol had any connection to racism
at all
no clue
but of course you know of course they
didn't know that because it doesn't have
any connection also the only way they'd
even know that the symbol supposedly is
connected to racism is if they spend a
lot of time on twitter because that's
the only place you'll see this
but most kids their age don't use
twitter as their social media poison of
choice so
three fake racist incidents in our
schools in a span of a couple weeks
mass hysteria
and when i say hysteria of course this
is not hysteria from the people
amplifying all of this encouraging it
they're not being hysterical they're
being quite intentional in their actions
but the plan is to make everybody else
hysterical
because when we are in the throes of
mass hysteria
we can be manipulated
we're at their mercy
and that of course is their plan
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well the tax filing deadline is around
the corner and with it brings irs
scammers looking to steal your money and
personal information which is basically
what the irs does so how do you tell the
difference between the two really the
most common scams though take place on
the phone or via email be smart never
give information out or send money to
anyone over the phone always ask for
everything in writing and only interact
with websites that end with dot gov
it's important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives every day we put our
information at risk on the internet in
an instant a cyber criminal could steal
what's yours sometimes even harm your
finances your credit your reputation all
of it is on the line good thing there's
lifelock lifelock helps detect a wide
range of identity threats like your
social security number for sale in the
dark web you have access to a dedicated
restoration specialist if you become a
victim so you have many layers of
protection no matter what happens
look nobody can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can help protect
what's yours with lifelock by norton
join now and save up to 25 off your
first year at lifelock.com walsh that's
lifelock.com walsh or 25 off
all right there's um so much going on in
the world it's hard to fit it all into
five headlines not that in the five
headline segment i actually don't do
five headlines i mean sometimes it's
like two headlines sometimes it's 12. so
five headlines you know we'll change the
name of the segment to five headlines
give or take
uh so we'll start here zelensky
president of ukraine
addressed congress
um today and he's uh he's kind of doing
the world tour here all through zoom but
he's talked to um
you know he was he
addressed canadian lawmakers i think a
few days ago so he's kind of going
around
and in addressing congress here in the
united states
he evoked 911
evoked pearl harbor
and also the i had a dream speech so
he's kind of greatest hits here throwing
it all in there
and as to the latter we have that clip
let's listen to
that have a dream these words are known
to each of you today i can say i have a
need
i need to protect
our sky i need your decision your help
which means exactly the same the same
you feel when you hear the words i have
a dream
ladies and gentlemen
friends
ukraine is grateful to the united states
for its overwhelming support for
everything that your government and your
people have done for us for weapons
and ammunition for training for finances
for leadership in the free world which
helps us to pressure the aggressor
economically i'm grateful to president
biden for his personal involvement
for his sincere commitment to the
defense of ukraine and democracy all
over the world i am grateful to you for
the resolution which recognizes all
those who commit crimes against ukraine
against the ukrainian people as war
criminals however now
it is true in the darkest time for our
country for the whole europe i call on
you to do more new packages of sanctions
are needed
constantly every week so he has a dream
he wants us to protect the skies she
wants us to do more um
and when he talks about protecting the
skies of course what he means is what he
what he wants most of all
is a no-fly zone and that's what he's
been asking for talking to you know the
uk canada the united states has been
asking for a no-fly zone
uh that's that's what he wants now
i
as i've been saying all along about this
and about zelinski i understand
why he would want a no-fly zone um i
understand why he would want
the united states to get involved
directly and militarily in this conflict
so i get why why he wants that
okay because he's worried about ukraine
it's his job to be worried about ukraine
he's not worried about the united states
though
that's that's not on his list of
concerns
he's not he's not concerned about how
many american deaths would follow if we
got into a direct conflict with russia
because that's what a no-fly zone would
mean i feel like this is something that
needs to be explained to people because
i think i'm not sure if everyone really
understands when you hear no fly zone
i think what people imagine i don't know
but
uh just based on the way they talk about
it how casually it's discussed by some
people especially on social media
it's
they appear to think that
a no-fly zone is like a force field that
we can magically put over ukraine to
make sure that no planes
fly over it and drop any bombs
and by the way
if we could if that was an option if we
had a magical force field and we could
and we could
set it up over ukraine then i would say
yeah let's let's definitely set up the
force field
but that's not what it is
um and also what a no-fri fly zone is
it's also not like a gun-free zone
where you just post signs all around
you know that's that's also not what
we're doing we're not just posting signs
saying no flying here russia
no it means it means shooting down
russian planes
okay means active direct military
engagement with russia it means getting
involved in a war with russia that's
what it means
and that's what he would like to see
happen
which would result
you know now that we're
now we're in a war with another major
power a nuclear power we're risking
nuclear war which apparently according
to pew a third of americans are okay
with
they're not really okay with it
but again they're in they're in the
throes of hysteria they don't really
know what they're saying
if they stop to think for a minute about
what that would actually mean
okay think about because this is what
you're saying now
you're saying that you'd be okay with
nuclear war potentially to protect
ukraine
okay we'll just stop for a second
and imagine what it would mean for a
nuclear bomb to be dropped on a major
american city
okay just think about that you're really
okay with that potentially the risk of
that for ukraine
a country you don't know a damn thing
about
a country that three weeks ago
you never thought about up until three
weeks ago you never thought once about
it in your life ever never thought about
ukraine
and now you're willing to risk the
nuclear destruction of american cities
for its sake
that's not thinking that's not clear
thinking
it's just not
now they're
i'm not saying that this is a an overly
simple situation war never is
and there are different points of view
people can have
the level of involvement of the united
states what what we do to help do we
help at all i mean there's you know
there's varying degrees different
opinions people can have as intelligent
people
but to purposefully get involved in a
military conflict with russia which
would which would lead to a world war
i'm not saying it would definitely lead
to nuclear annihilation although that's
on the table when you get into a world
war and everybody has nuclear weapons
but it would certainly lead i think
to a world war
you have to think about what that means
and that's what zelinski wants for his
sake and for the sake of ukraine
fine i understand why he wants it
but this is why the the fawning
treatment of this guy
i i just find it is very disturbing to
me
because when you're fawning over
somebody and treating them like a god
in fact i just saw there was um
i forget who it is but
a a band a singer just put out and it
was getting a lot of praise for this and
you know he was doing the rounds on
cable news
uh performing this song that he wrote as
a tribute to zielenski and the name of
the song is can one man save the world
maybe i'll find that we'll play it for
you tomorrow play a clip of it um
and people are loving this song and it's
all about zelensky about how he's taking
a stand to save the world
talking about him literally like a
christ figure
and the problem with doing that is first
of all sacrilegious to talk about
anybody that way
but especially in a situation like this
because when you're talking about a guy
like he's a hollywood
uh
hero
or or something more than that
an actual savior of humanity a messianic
figure
then you're not thinking rationally
and you're not thinking about what he is
actually trying to get us involved in
and what that would mean for us and our
families and our children
also i'll tell you this right now
zielinski
shoes on the other foot you know
you think you think zielenski is getting
involved he's sending ukraine ukrainian
troops to defend america
you think he's doing that
do you think shoes on the other foot do
you think that zelensky would risk
thousands of ukrainian lives
for the sake of us you think he'd do
that
we all know he wouldn't
we all know he wouldn't
yet another one of our great allies who
we all know would never do this for us
ever
and yet we think we're obligated to do
it for them it's crazy to me
um
all right
this is from the daily wire it says
nearly two-thirds of americans support
the key measure features of florida's hb
1557
uh parental rights and education
proposal
so we've got we've got one terrible
thing that that uh
you know a third of americans supposedly
support but then we've got two thirds
who support something good um this is
according to a new poll released on
monday by the daily wire the national
poll of us adults was conducted over the
weekend by market research technology
platform lucid on behalf of the daily
wire the survey as surveys a thousand
person sample was 37 democrat 32
republican 31 independent
um unlike unlike other surveys that have
relied on a summary of the legislation
written by pollsters the daily wires
researchers presented the respondents in
its study with the actual language from
the florida's bill
and it's the most criticized passage and
then asked them to react to it
who would have thought you know i mean
what do you know when you actually tell
people what's in the bill itself and you
don't say
yeah if you ask people should there be a
bill
where if you say the word gay
you're sent to gitmo
what do you know if you ask people that
most of them are going to say no no i
don't think i support that bill it seems
a little bit seems a little overboard
you tell them what the bill actually
says and how limited it is
far too limited in my opinion
we're not going to teach
sexuality sexual orientation and gender
identity to kids in grades six through
three are k through three
you tell them that in most americans
more than six in ten americans 64
support the florida bills ban on
classroom classroom instructions on
sexual orientation and gender identity
in grades k through 3.
21 said they oppose the bill
the florida measure is backed by 69 of
republicans 62 percent of democrats and
57 percent of independents
there was also no notable differences
among whites blacks and latinos they're
all in the 60 range actually
uh the black respondents were had the
highest
in in favor of the bill 66
63 for white people latinos
62
um
and that's what happens when you
actually tell them what the bill says
most americans when you when you when
you ask them
do you think that seven-year-olds should
be taught about transgenderism in school
most americans say no now
that's the uh glass half full that's the
you know that's the the optimistic way
of reading this that's the majority of
americans are opposed to this
if you want to look at it from the more
pessimistic end then you you might say
only 62 percent
are opposed to teaching that kind of
stuff to
to seven-year-olds
that's the other way you might look at
this that you know 62 percent is still
or 64 rather 64 that's good it's a
majority and so
you make the point
majority of americans are actually in
favor of this bill that the left is
treating like um like it's like
armageddon
and they're in favor of it when you tell
them the actual language
but the the negative side of that which
you know i
i like to always take a gander at the
negative side of the coin as well
because i like to be a realist
um and that tells you that
okay 64 say we shouldn't teach
transgenderism to seven-year-olds
you know that leaves
a pretty sizable number of americans who
uh do not have that opinion
or either in favor of teaching it or
don't care either way
which to me is somehow the most
disturbing if you have no opinion you
can't be bothered to care
and the thing is if you were to ask this
same exact question 10 years ago
you know you put this bill on the table
10 years ago
uh i i think the first reaction to from
everybody would be well why would you
need this i mean no one would ever
we don't need this bill no one would
ever even
conceive of teaching this stuff to
little kids
but almost everyone would agree that yes
we should not be teaching it
it would but it would seem like a
conversation that doesn't need to be had
in the first place
now you have a certain preponderance of
americans who are actually actively in
favor
of teaching this stuff to kids
it shows you the kind of soul rot and
the mental rot
that afflicts our country
speaking of soul rot and mental rock the
surgeon general
dr vivek murthy has
chimed in on the florida bill and this
is what he says florida's recent law
restricting discussions about gender
identity in school has understandably
raised serious concern the law concerns
me too let me explain why
learning that people are different and
that not all families look the same
these are important lessons that start
early in life including in school they
help create a society based on
understanding and respect they help
children know they belong even if
they're different i grew up in florida
and i'm a proud graduate of the public
school system as a kid who often felt i
didn't belong it helped tremendously
when teachers openly discussed our
different backgrounds this built
understanding and reduced shame
lgbtq youth
also deserve such proactive support
preventing or criminalizing efforts to
foster such understanding hurts kids and
families it shuts down dialogue instead
of nurturing healthy conversation and it
sends a signal to lgbtq youth that
they're not fully accepted so he's
finding a more wordy way to do it and
he's being
a little bit more subtle
but he's still
hammering on this for this propaganda
this false narrative that this is a bill
that forbids people from saying the word
gay he doesn't he doesn't he doesn't
mention the don't say gay bill
um
but this is what he's basically claiming
that the bill would somehow prevent
classrooms and students and teachers
from acknowledging the existence of
various different kinds of people
that's not what the bill does
and also by the way kids in a modern
classroom
you don't need to have lessons teaching
them
that there are different
but what was he saying learning that
that people are different and not all
families look the same
you actually at no point even need to
sit kids down and tell them that because
they can see it for themselves
they can look around them
in a modern public school classroom
especially in a place like florida and
they can look around and see that oh
yeah people all look different
but you don't need to talk about it at
all they can see that that's the world
they live in
talk about lived experience that is
their that is their lived experience
so you don't need to talk about it it's
not a discussion that needs to be had
but that's also not what the bill does
it's got nothing to do with that
despite that um
that piece of propaganda that ridiculous
commercial that we played last week
claiming that the bill would mean that
if a a child who has two mommies
mentions both of her mommies in class an
alarm will sound
and the teacher will be immediately
fired that's actually not what the bill
does
all it does is it says that we're not
going to have lesson plans about
gender identity and sexuality
okay you're not going to talk to a
seven-year-old about that
all right let's um
move to this from the wall street
journal a pair of california lawmakers
introduced a bill that aims to hold
technology companies liable for social
media addictions that may affect
children the bill would let parents and
guardians sue platforms that they
believe addicted children in their care
through advertising push notifications
and design features that promote
compulsive behavior particularly the
continual consumption of harmful content
on issues such as eating disorders and
suicide it would hold companies
accountable regardless of whether they
deliberately design their products to be
addictive the bill called the social
media platform duty to to children act
was introduced tuesday by state assembly
members jordan cunningham and buffy
wicks once a democrat once a republican
the bills were written to improve
children's experiences online from two
different angles
so that's what this is about it's about
improving their experiences and holding
these tech companies responsible for
making kids addicted to the content
i think it tells you something that this
is supposed to be a bill protecting
children
and protecting them when they're online
and if you want to do that then the very
first thing that you should be doing
is
everything possible to restrict
pornographic content
because the worst thing that's happening
to kids online is that ages as young as
seven or eight or even younger they're
being exposed to hardcore pornography
they're being exposed to the kinds of
sexual images
that most people through history never
in their lives would have ever been
exposed to even as adults and now we've
got eight-year-olds
whose minds are marinating in this kind
of filth
and who um
go through their formative years
marinating in it
and suffer the consequences for a
lifetime so if you really want to
protect kids that should be the first
thing your bill accomplishes
as far as i can tell with this bill it
doesn't even touch on that
instead they're concerned with
push notifications that's kind of the
the fact that it makes kids addicted now
i'm all about holding the big tech
companies responsible
i'm certainly all about protecting kids
um
and that's why i say
when it comes to the kind of content
that these companies allow to
proliferate on their platforms
the fact that there's
no barriers put in place at all
kid can go online and within two seconds
you can access anything
that to me is crazy and anything done
to address that issue is a is a positive
step
but also we have to acknowledge
that
if your kid is addicted
to the internet
if he's addicted to social media
yeah it's true that social media
companies they want that they're doing
everything they can
to to make it to to form this into a
compulsion
and that's not good that's that's evil
in fact
but also if you're if your child if your
nine-year-old has a compulsive need
to use social media
that's primarily your own fault
so we we have to always turn the mirror
around
so that parents can see themselves
that's on you
as i've said a million times
especially younger kids
your ability to control
you you have a profound ability to
control
their access to the internet how much
time they spend on it
now you might not be able to completely
control it especially if they're going
to school and they've got friends who
have phones and that kind of thing
so you can't completely control it but
whether or not your own child has a
phone that's a big one
your nine-year-old's not going on buying
his own phone
if he has a phone cause you bought it
for him just don't buy it
that one decision don't buy the phone
for or if you do buy the phone don't buy
a phone that has internet capacity at
all
buy a dumb phone buy a phone that only
makes it can only call two people it can
call you know call his parents it can
call 9-1-1
give him that phone then you've got then
you could keep track of them uh any
safety concerns are taken care of
no problem
you can do that
you give him a phone that has access to
the entire entire
you know wild west of the internet then
that's on you
and his internet addiction
and his compulsion which he will develop
and so many kids have developed i mean
almost every kid you see now
has a compulsive need
uh to look at their phone every 10
seconds but that's that's a decision
that you made as a parent i think
all right
so here's another
i wanted to play this for you because
this was a lot of fun as well
you know of course georgia tech
two nights ago
um speaking out about the
the male invasion of sports and as we
saw you know protesters came out and
they were very upset
but many of them couldn't actually
explain
why they were there what they were upset
about i think this kind of ties into the
whole mass hysteria theme of this show
so campus reform they were also on the
scene and here's another fun interview
with uh with a protester he's got he's
you know he's come out he's got all the
protesters behind him they've got the
trans flag they got all the signs
and uh can he explain why he's there and
what he's so upset about let's see
tell us why you're out here today i'm
standing for trans rights
do you think there's a biological
difference between men and women
biological
i would stand for lesbian gay
lgb bisexual
and trans community
why are you guys out here yelling
instead of maybe going inside i mean
there's a q a you guys have the
opportunity to go and ask well it's a
question don't you think that would be
more
uh productive when it comes to
republicans republicans are more
argumentative more
my way
don't you think this might be my way the
highway here
[Music]
uh you could not have scripted any
better that was great he
they were they were literally chanting
in the background hey hey ho ho uh was
it matt walsh has to go or this fascist
has to go whatever it was
that's what they're chatting in the
background while the guy in the front
claims
that republicans are the ones who are
the it's my way or the highway
um
you couldn't
you could have scripted any better that
was great
but of course he you know he couldn't
really explain why he was there i'm here
for trans rights
are men and women different biologically
oh what uh what do you mean biologically
i'm not even sure i'm a college student
i don't know what the word biologically
means
so they didn't know why they were there
but this is
again for them it's it's a it's hysteria
they're not they're not they they don't
really know why they're there or what
they're doing
but um
pulling the strings the people who are
encouraging this
you know there's that that's a very
intentional choice
all right i want to play one other thing
for you quickly herschel walker is
running for for senate and um
he was trending online yesterday
and one thing you know
general rule of thumb
if you're a republican candidate for
office and you're trending online it's
it's never for anything good right so he
was uh he was trending because he was
recently at looks like a church and he
was giving his views on things he
started to riff on evolution and is now
being mocked ruthlessly for what he said
about it
let's listen
so when the light was created here that
means somebody up there had to say let
there be light that the earth started
and then he had to put someone there on
earth because remember adam was there
remember adam came there then eve came
so somebody had to start it out
so that means it had to be a god because
he didn't just some bomb blew up and it
started out and then i'll tell you
something else i heard and i think about
this
because at one time science said man
came from apes
did it now
that's when you go to the same time
every time i read or hear that i think
to myself you just didn't read the same
bible i did well this was interesting
though
if that is true
why are there still apes
think about it you know now you're
getting too smart for it no no no no
think about this we have an evolution
that is we've gotten so intelligent
that if that is true why are they still
apes
yeah you know i see i i struggle with
this and i get kind of frustrated
because i mean i appreciate someone
running for office sharing their faith i
think it's a wonderful thing
um
but
i i don't like it when christians go out
and say things that reinforce the
stereotype which says that christianity
is not compatible with science and that
one must choose science or christianity
and the reason i don't like it it's not
because i care when people are making
fun of us um
the reason that i care
is because it's it's not true first of
all it's just not true that christianity
and science aren't compatible or that
christians in general are ignorant of
science it's not true at all and very
often the truth goes the other way
around where where what we find is that
people in the secular leftist religion
are
truly the anti-science ones who believe
that men can get pregnant and so on and
so forth so
that's the truth and i care about people
knowing the truth
but also this is uh this is a line
a false narrative that i think is
persuasive
to people who are not religious but are
sort of considering it and the people
who could be reached who could be saved
i think when they're told that well
you know that christianity that's
anti-science and it's you you gotta i
think for many people in that camp that
that becomes a persuasive argument for
them
and then uh people that could be reached
ultimately are not because of that
and that's why scientific ignorance when
it's displayed
in a christian context
can be harmful i think and also another
thing makes it frustrating is that it's
such an unforced error there's just no
reason to do it
so
here's what i'm saying
um if you if you don't if you don't know
much about evolution
that's fine
that's okay
no big deal um you're running for office
doesn't matter it really doesn't matter
how you feel about evolution doesn't you
know
doesn't make a difference and so just
don't don't talk about it don't go on
stage talking about it the problem here
for hershey walker is that he doesn't
understand the theory
um the theory does not say that humans
came from apes that's not the theory
that's that's just not it
um the theory states that apes and
humans have a common ancestor
okay and that's not semantics that we're
not splitting hairs here it's just a
very different sort of thing
so
in other words the point is it's not
that apes are our great grandparents
it's that in this analogy there are
cousins
um according to the theory of evolution
now
think what you want about it say what
you want about it but that is the theory
common descent as they call it
so if you want to try to debunk it or
whatever or express your disagreement
that's what you're disagreeing with
and so you say that and it just opens up
the floodgates and it's again it's an
unforced error there's no reason to do
that
um but if you if you do want to go down
i mean i would say if you're running for
office as a christian there's really no
reason to go down this path at all but
if you're gonna do it
at least know what it is first so that
you don't open yourself up to this
all right one other thing quickly this
was interesting apparently an asteroid
hit earth a few days ago um sadly it
didn't do much damage burned up in the
in the atmosphere once again we were so
close to all of our problems being
solved but yet so far the bigger issue
is the headline from the daily mail and
the headline says asteroid half the size
of a giraffe strikes earth off the coast
of iceland
now
i know the media sometimes struggles to
describe things like asteroids on a
scale that will make sense to the
average viewer
and so that's why they come up with this
but i'm not sure that you're helping
matters by using giraffes
as a measuring unit
not even a whole giraffe like if you
said oh it's an asteroid the size of a
giraffe it's like okay well that i can
conceive of that a little bit but now
i'm sort of imagining an asteroid in the
shape of a giraffe
uh but okay the size of a giraffe fine
but half giraffes
that's the measuring unit it's by half
dr
which half of the draft are we talking
about how are we splitting it we
splitting it down the middle
and is it a male or a female giraffe
because they're different sizes so so
many questions are raised and also how
do you convert this unit of measurement
into uh let's say otters
i think it's 57 so an asteroid the size
of 57 otters hit the earth or maybe we
could say an asteroid the size of 114
half-sized otters
hit the earth
i guess we'd have a lot of fun with this
measuring skill let's get now to the
comment section
[Applause]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
all right dailywire.com sweet baby
comments let's check clip number eight
hey man out here just returning my cart
um
unfortunately i just learned
that my own father
is a member of the cult that leaves
their carts out in the street as he just
told me
to leave mine
by the side of the car naturally of
course i instantly disowned him
and now i'll be taking you
adopting you as my
sweet new daddy so
sweet daddy walsh you have a new son
sweet little john boy so
sweet baby game for your life and uh
we'll see you at home
is your dad in the car with you when
you're saying all of this
are you kind of well but look you you
did the right thing and i i appreciate
that my son
you uh you saw something and you said
something that's what that's what we
need and it doesn't matter familial
units and
bonds
i think are very important to me i'm a
you know i'm a big advocate of the
family
and i think fathers are very important
but there are limits
and those bonds can be dissolved i think
over something like a shopping cart it's
serious enough for that
rob green says wow matt those protesters
really found your kryptonite that you
can't swim how will you possibly recover
i mean it would be my kryptonite if they
threw me into the ocean or something so
in a literal sense but i still don't
know what it had to do with what we were
talking about uh jonathan richter says
matt
society needs more men also matt
doggy paddles
well
look
i admit it's it's hard to look manly
when you're doggy paddling
but the only reason i would ever be in
that position in the first place as if
i'm is if i did get thrown out into the
ocean or something like that and i'm
drowning so that i'm probably not gonna
be worried too much about style points i
just yeah i never really i never learned
the proper form for swimming but i
because it's just it's not something
that ever comes up in my life
you know when when i see a body of water
rarely do i think that i want to be
inside it like i like to go over top it
in a
kayak or a boat or something so i can go
fishing that's fun
but i rarely have the experience of i
see a big laker like i want to be in the
water
i just i don't i don't have that
instinct
um
let's see
evie says matt if you can manage without
a microwave in your home then you should
see if you can manage without a
television
then you don't have to put so much
effort into censoring what your kids are
watching
uh
hey i got nothing but respect for people
that go without televisions in the home
i don't
for me though see a phone
phone and television there's two
different things when it comes to with
kids
um i think there's just no circumstance
as i've said where you give your
say nine-year-old
a phone
um
and also because once you give them the
phone with internet access one of the
big problems is that it's just not going
to be possible for you to monitor all
the times when they're using it you're
not going to be able to do that
tv is very different so our policy with
the tv we have one tv in the house so
that is our that's our one
that's that's the that's the
the one rejection of modern society what
comes to the tv for us is that we only
have one
which even that's how bad it's gotten
that that seems shocking to people most
people have i think in fact the house
that we live in right now when we moved
in
they had a tv in literally every room of
the house i mean the kitchen the
bathroom everywhere
so i guess they would put a show on
and then so and then they could just
move from room to room and watch the
show and never miss a second of any show
um that that's crazy to me
so we have one tv
it's in a public area of the house you
know we don't do tvs in bedrooms
we certainly would never do tv in a
kid's bedroom asking for problems there
one tv public area
and um
and we can easily control when they
watch the tv what they watch
not a lot of effort actually has to go
into it it's pretty it's pretty low
effort thing with kids this is when
you're allowed to watch tv
no you're not allowed to watch that you
are allowed to watch that
pretty low effort
jesse says matt the problem with your
nba versus wnba player criticism analogy
regarding westbrook is that in order for
taunting to occur there must first be
fans to watch the game
well i guess that is the one thing that
protects the wnba from taunting you're
right i mean there's no fans in the
stands although
really
that makes the taunting even worse in
the wnba because if there are fans in
the stands it's only going to be family
members
and so if you're getting taunted at a
wnba game it's like your own mother
who's doing it and that makes it all the
worse i guess
as you all know by now the daily wire
does not stop creating awesome new
content and we're super excited about
our latest docu-series fauci unmasked
the show exposes the most successful
failure in government history dr anthony
fauci hosted by our very own michael
knowles he'll peel back the mask on
fauci's past and shows the world's
leading scientists for what he really is
which is a fraud the first episode
dropped this morning and explores fauci
as the voice of the aids crisis in the
80s the results well it's the kind of
thing you have to really see to believe
check out the trailer
he's the highest paid employee in our
federal government
and beginning in the spring of 2020 dr
fauci began to set national policy that
affected the way that 330 million
americans lived their lives for goodness
sakes i'm telling you wear a mask keep
social distancing there's nothing
political about that but who is anthony
fauci people who have conspiracy
theories those are people that don't
particularly care for me in this short
series
we will do what the establishment media
have refused to do
we will give you an unvarnished look at
the career of the most powerful
politician in america
dr anthony thatcher don't you think it's
time that you step down and let someone
else who has a more effective message
actually no
the three-part series will be dropping
an episode a day starting today and
ending this friday and it's available
exclusively at the daily wire you don't
want to miss this if you're not a member
yet head to dailywire.com subscribe to
join today the show is excellent and
since we're only adding more content
every day you don't want to miss it go
become a subscriber today also if it's
true it's probably not getting published
that's why the daily wire is changing uh
everything with our own publishing wing
dw books and we're proud to be
publishing two books that are actively
fighting the left's monopoly on
storytelling the first is 12 seconds in
the dark by sergeant mattingly the book
is the true story of what really
happened the night of the bronte brianna
taylor shooting mattingly as a 20-year
police veteran takes readers inside his
department's response
and debunks the lies that have
recklessly been shared with the public
check out the trailer it was very
chaotic it was very quick
instantly i knew it was shot brianna
taylor she was caught in the crossfire
of those bullets as soon as your brain's
registering it's already over the media
gets so many things wrong in this case
saying we had the wrong apartment her
name wasn't on the warrant she was shot
and killed in her sleep in her bed these
are lies this is not true and all the
while you're hearing all these outside
influences from athletes and oprah and
ellen degeneres and kamala harris and
joe biden all those people coming and
attacking you putting your name on their
account saying he should be in prison
all these things that they have no idea
what they're talking about but they have
such influence the more we attack police
for doing their job the less good
qualified police you're going to have
[Music]
when you read 12 seconds in the dark you
will find out the truth of what really
happened the night of the brianna taylor
raid
[Music]
in a world where voices like his are
censored this story is incredibly
important and we're so grateful to have
this brave truth teller on board the
book is available now on amazon or
anywhere you buy books online so go
order your copy today because i can
promise you it will sell out now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
here's a rule that will never steer you
wrong the second worst thing the
government does are the things that
democrats do by themselves the third
worst are the things republicans do by
themselves but the worst of all are the
things that the two sides agree to do
together the bipartisan things
so
one example which we
may tragically see again in the near
future are all of the disastrous
military conflicts we've been involved
in over recent decades those were all
bipartisan
um
things
here's another example perhaps slightly
less serious but but maybe not
and it happened yesterday when the
senate passed by unanimous consent the
so-called sunshine protection act
i haven't heard of a bill
this uh misleadingly named since the you
know don't don't say gay bill even
though that wasn't really the name of
the bill the sunshine protection act
this bill greeted with much applause and
fanfare by many in the public would make
daylight savings time permanent
now that's not to say that it would
abolish daylight savings no it would it
would keep us stuck in daylight savings
eternally
the hour that we lost when we jumped
ahead a few days ago will never be
recovered it's gone forever it's
banished to purgatory never to be seen
again
now the idea behind this proposal is for
one thing to uh end the silly ritual
where we switch our clocks back and
forth arbitrarily that's the part that
most everybody can agree with and i
agree with you know we've been switching
our clocks back and forth for decades
nobody knew why nobody wanted to do it
yet the daylight savings tradition
continued lingering on hanging there
uselessly like some kind of vestigial
limb
and it was time to end it
that's good but the question is whether
we end the tradition by making daylight
savings permanent or by reverting back
to standard time and just leaving the
clocks there
out of these two options congress of
course has chosen the worst one electing
to turn daylight savings into a chronic
condition
two of the senators behind this ploy
marco rubio and edward markey
wrote an op-ed for cnn congratulating
themselves and extolling the brilliance
of their plan they wrote quote
we can always we can't always get
bipartisan agreement in congress these
days but here's one thing we can agree
on
we could all use a bit more sunshine
that's why we're working together in the
u.s senate to make sure we end the
practice of spring forward and fall back
by making daylight savings time
permanent
yes they say the sunshine protection act
will literally protect the sunshine by
giving us more of it now i find it
necessary to point out that no matter
what the clocks say
there will be exactly the same amount of
sunshine regardless
now congress may imagine itself to be
powerful enough to literally control the
sun itself but it's not we're not giving
ourselves more sunshine this way we're
not giving ourselves anything we're
merely agreeing by legislative decree
to permanently pretend that it's an hour
later than it really is but why
why are we doing this
where did this come from what the hell
is going on
well let's go through a brief history of
this madness and i i think most of what
i'm about to say is basically true but i
didn't care enough to look it up so
we'll just we'll go with it
daylight savings was first proposed by i
believe benjamin franklin as a joke
250 years ago
he told it to his buddies at a bar and
everybody laughed and said ah there's
old benny again with his wild schemes
and for the next 100 years people
continue to laugh at the joke and then
in the 1890s a weirdo bug collector
named george something or other decided
that he wanted more time after work to
stare at crickets and beetles this this
megalomaniac actually wanted to shift
time itself
just to accommodate his pointless hobby
one hobby that i enjoy is night fishing
okay i like to go out fishing at night
but you don't see me suggesting that we
blow up the sun so i can do it more
often
that's essentially what george wanted to
do slightly less drastic but still a
significant change
now fast forward to 1918 when daylight
savings time was officially instated
here in the usa
our lawmakers at the time they didn't
say they were doing this so that a guy
named george could look at beetles
instead they said that we were doing it
for a few reasons most importantly to
save energy
now
how could changing the numbers on a
clock save energy how could it achieve
anything at all who knows but we did it
and since then studies have proven that
this policy like almost all government
policies you can name utterly failed to
achieve whatever it was supposed to
achieve it didn't save energy it didn't
force the sun to give us more daylight
it didn't usher in an era of utopia it
didn't do anything except annoy
everybody
and now after a hundred years of this
failed government policy
the government's decided to do what it
always does when a policy fails which is
make it permanent
if it didn't work do it more that's the
motto of our elected leaders
but many people in the public are
celebrating this policy as i mentioned
they insist that this will now give us
more sunlight during waking hours
of course what they apparently don't
realize is that there's another way to
have more sunlight during waking hours
wake up earlier
but now people don't want to wake up
earlier they don't want to adjust their
schedules instead they prefer to
manipulate time itself or try to
manipulate i mean
you could either adjust your schedule or
adjust time itself
which one should we do oh i know well
just time
this is how lazy we've become as a
society
never mind the fact that your extra hour
of daylight after work now means that
school children are gonna be walking to
the bus stop in the pitch black for
several months out of the year maybe
some safety hazards there you think
that'd be enough reason not to do this
but who cares about safety if it means
that you can have more sunlight after
work sunlight that you're going to
squander anyway by just sitting on your
couch and watching netflix i like all
these people pretending that i want more
sunlight when i get over work so i can
go for a jog you're not jogging you're
gonna sit on your couch on your phone is
what you're gonna do stop pretending
otherwise
what we should be doing it's obvious
is abolish daylight savings entirely and
revert back to standard time
now standard time is a human construct
in the sense that any method of
measuring time will inevitably be a
human construct but it was far less
arbitrary okay standard time
was more closely aligned with the body
circadian rhythm and with the rising and
setting of the sun
that's why standard time was devised
that's where it comes from
in fact it's it's more important for
your body and your mind to have sunlight
in the morning than at night
it's not natural to have sunlight that
late at night
your body wants to wake up with the sun
that's how we're designed
daylight savings is unnatural it's an
attack on nature and creation itself
we will have to answer for this come
judgment day
one other point not to make too much of
this
too late i guess
but there's another serious problem as i
was discussing this on twitter yesterday
many people insisted that um well we can
and should make daylight savings
permanent because time is an illusion
it's a construct and we can do with it
whatever we please
this of course is completely false our
method of measuring and keeping time is
a construct but time itself is real time
is simply the progression of reality
from one moment to the next time ensures
that everything won't happen all at once
time is what keeps you from getting
eaten by a t-rex time is the movement
and flow of
existence yet these claims from the
anti-time agitators only show how
congress by making daylight savings
permanent has undermined faith and
confidence in the reality of time itself
the united states senate has caused many
people to question the very meaning and
existence of time
they've created a mass existential
crisis
one which threatens the foundations of
human society recklessly the senate
passed this bill without even grabbing
grappling with these questions and
implications without even first
establishing
what time is where it comes from or if
it exists at all
are the past and future but illusions
are we trapped forever
in in eternal now
legislation raises these questions
doesn't answer them and now we're lost
mass anarchy madness and despair will be
the result
so not much of a change on second
thought i guess even so for all these
reasons
i hereby declare that as far as i'm
concerned
daylight savings is cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
usa today lists a man among the women of
the year criminal justice reform claims
some more victims and san francisco
boycotts most of the united states check
it out on the michael knowles show